Hey what's up Zev here from esy.com.
So I just got the alert Claude Fable 5 and Claude Mythos 5. It
seems Claude Fable is the new segment
of Mythos. It's a piece
of Mythos. It's not as big and bad but it's going to
be some kind of variation of Mythos but it's better than Opus
which is crazy. So I just got the update on youtube.
I wanted to check it out and do a little review. I'm
going to test it later in Claude code as well as
cursor because I'm already doing some work on that.
So it's going to be interesting to see
how this works out because we've been pretty
disappointed with 4.7 and 4.8.
We see some marginal improvements. Some people have seen some
regressions. So you can't really say if the additional
models 4.7 and 4.8 are dramatically better
than 4.6. So a couple of months ago when 4.6
came out it was a massive hit. People were
disappointed with 4.7 and then from
my read on Twitter and so forth 4.8
wasn't that much better in terms of how
other people benchmark these models.
Which is really hard to do because you can't really trust the companies
word for it when they actually list the results
that they get and the benchmarks. So the usual
best case is that you'll plug these models into your own
workflows and then judge for yourself how much better
it is at being able to do work compared to the previous models
for your special use
case. And that's another benefit of what I'm working on
at esy.com
where we essentially build agentic workflow
templates around digital assets like clipart,
essays. These are just some of the few that I've needed
so far. Infographics, I'll be building more out.
But the ability to be able to take something like say
a template like this for
a generic clipart asset, that's
not really very useful for Fable.
But to be able to plug and play with the models and then compare them
to each other is what I'm trying to say. And to be able to do that with
templates is a lot easier. So if you already have a template
that is known to produce a certain quality of
work for a certain type of asset, being able to plug
in a new model and produce a new template and compare it
to the old ones is something that could simplify that
kind of benchmark. But let's get back into it. So I haven't actually
even looked into this yet. So today we're launching Claude Fable 5,
a Mythos class model that we've made
safe for general use. Okay,
let's get straight into the benchmarks and see
what they're saying. So they're saying that agentic coding, they're
giving it 80%, 80.3% for Mythos Fable
5. Mythos preview, I've never tested this so
I don't know. I don't even know when that was released,
if it was released at all. Opus 4.8, 69.2%.
Interesting. So for agentic coding,
they're saying that Mythos 5 gets 80.3%
compared to 69.2% for Opus 4.8.
They gave 58.6% for GPT 5.5.
I don't know how many codex fans is going to agree
with this. That's pretty hilarious though. Gemini
3.1, yeah, Gemini, I actually have never used Gemini
for coding. It's never been a thought of mine. I should
see... Man, once you're just getting the
flow with these quality models, you don't even want to test your repo
on stuff like this. I would never put Grok on my repo,
let loose on my repo like that. Of course you could do a
git tree and then let it run loose, but... And you
should. You should. I'm more interested in the open source
solutions that claim to be on par with Opus
and GPT than to come down to
Gemini and Grok. Grok is
never in the conversation,
but... So agentic coding, software engineering,
bench pro, frontier code. I wonder, do people
really understand this stuff or are they
just all faking it? Because I get that
the frontier models putting these charts
up. I get that. But people reading it,
like a lot of these news guys reading it and claiming, I don't
think these people know what they're talking about, to be honest with
you. Frontier code, agentic coding, I don't even know what that means. I got
to look in... Because to actually study if these
benchmarks are accurate, you have to go in. You have to go in
on it. You can't just be reading these charts. You have to... Frontier
code, you got to look into frontier code. When I look at the news guys, they
never really go into that stuff. GDPval
for knowledge work, what does that
even mean? So we would have to go to this
source here and we have to go look at what they're saying constitutes
knowledge work and how they're measuring that. This
got 1932. This means nothing to anybody.
Of course, Gemini 3.1,
man. You can't catch a break.
I do like Gemini. I like talking to Gemini
to be honest, but knowledge work vision,
29 of course. Of course, Claude Mythos
is going to be the best. We'll see.
Maybe it is. Okay. At least they
gave this win to GPT. Spatial reasoning
blueprint. Spatial reasoning. 38.6.
These are some serious claims, but they admit that
Opus 4.8 only had 14.5%.
And then GPT-5 got 36.2 here.
So they're keeping you honest. Some people
like to keep it honest just so they can lie a little better
on some other metrics. But the people will decide.
You can put all these benchmarks up as much as you want, but
when the people get a hold of the model, they're going to test it in
the wild and it'll be that.
That'll be that. Tool use.
Okay. Man, it's just
kind of wondering what does Gemini's goal
at this point, if this is true.
Legal and Grok. For all of the claims on X about Grok,
I like talking with Grok. Grok is funny, but Grok is kind of like shits
and giggles. You know what I mean? It's like Grok is who you go to for
shits and giggles. When you're trying to do serious work, you
got to pull out Opus. You got to pull out GPT. You're not
using Grok for serious work. And in Gemini,
if you happen to be on Google and you need a quick
AI overview or if you want to dive deep into the AI
overview, you're comfortable using
Gemini. It's Google at the end
of the day. But Grok is never in the conversation for anything
but shits and giggles, essentially. Okay.
So this is interesting. And then there's a lot of talk about
this whole computer use thing. I haven't tested computer use yet. So
I don't know. Have any of you guys tested computer use yet?
Perplexity changed their whole... Perplexity
actually changed their whole thing. I just checked out
Perplexity today. They used to have a nice UI over
here where they used to show news. I would love
to go into Perplexity to just like, you know, go in on whatever
the latest news was. Now they just like a ChatGPT
clone. So why would I even use that and just go to
ChatGPT? You don't see anything anymore.
You don't see the news that they used to have.
You used to be able to chat with it regularly. And now they
have this whole computer. Everyone's going the whole computer
route. Perplexity computer. Or if you even check out Higgs
Field. I like to use Higgsfield in order to generate
some images and produce videos. And they're
going hard on this whole supercomputer
buzzword now. Which turn a simple chat into
production ready content at scale.
Production ready content at scale.
I mean I like Higgsfield. I don't understand
the whole computer thing. I have
to look into that. I have to look into
it. So Frontier code. Okay, so we got some
charts here. Agented coding. They got
a video here. Let's see what
this video is about. What
the hell? Okay, is that Pokemon?
It's just, what is this even doing? Claude Fable 5
beats Pokemon FireRed. Oh, what was the
point of that? A time lapse of Claude playing Pokemon.
Oh, FireRed from start to finish using only raw game screenshots
with no maps, navigation aids, or extra game
state information. Earlier Claude models needed a complex
helper harness to play Pokemon. Claude Fable 5 completed
the game with Vision Along. Oh, that's
pretty sick. That's sick. If that's true, that's
sick. Memory in long context, Fable 5 stays focused across millions
of tokens in long running tasks and improves its
outputs using its own notes. When we had the
model play the deck building game Slay the
Spire, giving it access to persistent file
based memory, improved its performance three times
more than for Opus 4.8. Fable also reached the game's
final act three times more often.
So this is a simulation, simulates the solar system
and predicts a solar eclipse. Okay,
this is all cool marketing stuff.
What's this? Protein complex. Okay, it's
kind of deep. Misaligned behavior.
Early feedback for Claude Fable 5. Okay,
so let's see what Cursor is saying. Well, Cursor
kind of, there's no reason why Cursor would
not pump it up. You know what I mean? Cursor
pumps up every model. Claude Fable 5 is the state of the art
model. I mean, they said that about many other things.
It's opened up, I mean, they said that when GPT 5.5, well,
GPT 5.5 is a great model though, but I feel like they say that
every single time there's a new model. And of course they have the incentive
to say that. It's opened up a class of long horizon problems that were out of reach
for early models. That says absolutely nothing.
Okay, Claude Fable 5 is the state of the art model on Cursor Bench.
Okay, that's meaningful, but it's opened up a class of long
horizon problems that were out of reach for early
models. Okay, let's see what we get. Claude Fable 5
is a real step forward for the developers GitHub service.
In our early testing, it took on complex long horizon
coding tasks with a level of autonomy and reliability
that exceeded previous benchmarks. But what excites
us most is the direction it points. A future where
developers can hand increasingly ambitious work to agents
and trust the results across the software
side. Okay, safeguards,
cool. Offensive cyber evaluations.
Okay. All right,
it's available everywhere today. Pricing for both models,
there we go. Let's get into the pricing. Let's get into it. For
both models is 10 per million input tokens and $50,
I'm sorry, $10 per million input tokens
and $50 per million output. Oh, that's
expensive. That's expensive.
Much more expensive than Opus 4.8. We expect demand for Fable 5
to be very high and difficult to predict. I mean, let's see if it really
delivers because Mythos was really like, you know,
this kind of like big bad, big
and bad, what's that? Terminator
like threat to cybersecurity, had to shut it down.
Could only give it to the US government in order
to use for mission critical exercises
and stuff like that. So let's see if this is
really it because there was a lot of hype around it.
If it's not, it's going to be pretty disappointing. So,
but I think, I think I actually don't know what to think. So I'm going
to try this out later today. I just wanted to kind of look into
this and to do this improv and but I'm
going to test this out in Claude
code and do a video on that and
then we can see how it works. But we got to come up with the right benchmarks
because I don't want to just do like what a lot of I see a lot of other and then
there's nothing wrong with it. I just don't want to kind of like make some
kind of like silly little animation or anything like that. I want to
actually see like, does it really work? So it takes time to kind
of come up with a good benchmark. I think though, if I come
up with a couple of them, then at least when these new models come out, I have
a good idea and I can actually compare them properly.
So it will be in the form of a workflow template and
I'll share it. Okay. So I'll see you guys in the
next one. Take care.